un rocher comme dernière pierre comme un
symbole du réaménagement du pont du
rotois re le rocher au granit avec bras
lièvre et ben a été choisi par une
dizaine de commanditaires il ya eu tout
le processus au travers notamment de la
fondation de france qui étaient
présentes et représentées ce matin et
puis surtout ce qui était important
c'est d'associer les habitants du
quartier au travers de ce dispositif les
nouveaux commanditaires travaille
énormément actuellement justement sur
l'art urbain et sur la rénovation et
d'entretien de 7 heures cet art urbain
parce que je pense que c'est tout à fait
de l'image d'innovation de création de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines et il faut
garder cette entité dans une oeuvre de
20 tonnes qui conclut un processus de
trois ans elle s'intègre au coeur de 5
hectares de terrains où se mêlent 500
logements une clinique une résidence
hôtelière et des équipements publics
c'est aussi encouragés par le ministère
de la culture dans le cas d'une d'une
démarche s'appelle un immeuble une
oeuvre ou qui encouragent les opérateurs
les promoteurs les aménageurs à insérer
de l'art dans les nouvelles
constructions ou dans l'aménagement de
nouveaux quartiers de penser par les
artistes daniel de vars et grégory
gicquel l'oeuvre est doté d'un bon pour
accueillir les passants